the south dakota attorney general faces
possible
impeachment and growing calls to resign
after police say he hit
and killed a man with his car last
september
jason roundsburg was charged with three
misdemeanors
he told detectives he thought he hit a
deer
after video of him being questions was
shared this week
a judge ordered that no more information
on the criminal investigation be
released
our lead national correspondent david
begno has the story and then quite
frankly
wham that is jason roundsburg south
dakota's attorney general
this was one of his interrogation videos
in which he appeared uncomfortable
and looked like he had a hard time
making eye contact with the
investigators who wanted to know what
happened i'm thinking it's a deer at
this point
roundsburg is south dakota's top law
enforcement officer
it was the night of september 12th 2020
roundsburg was heading home for a
republican fundraiser
driving down this rural road in the
central part of south dakota
when officials say he struck and killed
55 year old joseph beaver
who was walking down the side of the
road roundsburg called 9-1-1 that night
9-1 this is ali how can i help you well
aly i'm the attorney general
i hit something by highmore heads in the
middle of the road
one of the other things that we know
jason
is you weren't in the middle of the road
you were on the shoulder
roundsburg claims he didn't realize he
hit anyone
until he returned to the scene the next
day but investigators point out
inside of his damaged vehicle were the
victim's glasses
they're joe's glasses i wonder if i
weren't i wondered about that
so that means his face came through your
windshield
roundsburg is facing three charges but
they're all misdemeanors
you know before south dakota's governor
christie gnome was ordered to remove
those videos from the internet on
thursday
this is what she had to say about her
decision to release them these
interviews we specifically asked for the
family's consent to do that
so we are going to continue to ask the
family uh what to release what they're
okay with
throughout this process now a
spokesperson for the attorney general
said that the ag does not intend to
resign and at no time has this
issue impeded his ability to do the work
of the office
but still state lawmakers are planning
to move forward next week
with proceedings to impeach the attorney
general
for cbs this morning i'm david becknow
when you look at that interrogation it's
really disturbing one of the things the
officers pointed out is that mr beaver's
flashlight was still
on so they were saying it couldn't have
been a deer because
we know a deer doesn't have a flashlight
but the the light from the flashlight
was still on i'm sure the beaver family
has a lot of questions
those calls for him to resign are coming
from both sides republicans and
democrats
should be interesting how long he can
maintain that position investigators are
saying
you weren't in the middle of the road
you're on the shoulder and also how did
you not notice the
the glasses his office is saying it
doesn't impede his ability to do his job
if i hit somebody and kill them and they
came through my windshield i would have
trouble coming to work the next day
exactly right